be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books
so what I wanted to do here is have a
discussion on the story of how Wolverine
killed the Marvel Universe unfortunately
this is also our last story in this
series of people who have killed the
Marvel Universe and so hopefully you
guys have walked away from this video
series having had a pretty fun
experience a sope Wolverine kills the
Marvel Universe is actually a what-if
story written by Jimmy Robinson in
November of 2006 and was based on a
series called Wolverine enemy of the
state initially being introduced with
Wolverine vol 3 issues 20 through 25
the original enemy of the state was
written by Mark Miller in 2006 in my
video about the story of old man Logan
we had talked about how Wolverine had
fallen into a comic book no-man's land
after the x-men's decline in the early
2000s in an effort to restore interest
in his character while he maintained his
own comic series which sold a respectful
number of copies Marvel was continually
looking for ways to make Wolverine
stories more engaging to an audience
that was rapidly losing interest due to
his work on Marvel night spider-man as
well as ultimate x-men and ultimate
Fantastic Four Mark Miller was
approached to write the story bringing
us a scenario where Wolverine was lured
into a trap by the Japanese organization
the hand working in tandem with Hydra
in an effort to capture or kill
superheroes and brainwashed them to
operate as agents the hand and Baron von
Strucker started with Wolverine using
him as a means to steal documentation on
various technologies developed by Reed
Richards which could then be weaponized
while the original story of Wolverine
enemy of the state led to conflicts
between Wolverine and the x-men the
Avengers and virtually all other groups
and heroes in the Marvel Universe shield
was eventually able to capture Wolverine
and restore his mind with enemy of the
state being considered one of a few
stories at Wolverine solo series to
achieve a wide amount of acclaim its
popularity led to Marvel asking the
question what would happen if Wolverine
weren't captured and deprogrammed by
shield and continued to operate as an
agent of the hand and Hydra
and so the story initially picks up with
a meeting taking place between Captain
America Susan storm magneto and Kitty
Pryde while Captain America appears to
be the leader of this group what we find
is that they're speaking directly with
Nick Fury
who informs them that while the
overarching goal is to defeat the forces
of Hydra and the hand that Wolverine is
their immediate concern according to
Nick Fury Wolverine had previously
killed spider-man and that whenever he's
fighting a foe and gets stuck in a
situation that he can't escape from on
his own Hydra will teleport him out
providing him with the edge necessary to
win the fight now in addition to killing
spider-man Wolverine is shown to have
killed iron fists as he attempted to
protect Wolverine from the President of
the United States and in response to his
death Luke Cage attended to apprehend
Wolverine but was killed as well now
following the death of these two
individuals Wolverine cut a swath
through all of these superheroes in the
Marvel Universe and while each of these
superheroes died the hand was able to
effectively resurrect them by mystical
means and turn these heroes into agents
to fight on their behalf along with
Hydra but furthermore what we learn is
that during this rampage Wolverine had
gone toe to toe with Captain America and
while Steve Rogers managed to survive
the conflict unlike the original enemy
of a state event Captain America didn't
capture Wolverine and instead lost one
of his arms and one of his legs during
the conflict eventually the group
settles down and what appears to be one
of Nick Fury's bunkers which is expected
to protect them from the combined forces
of Hydra the hand and Wolverine the plan
that has been formed by this group as is
explained to us is that with his healing
factor in full force mold rain will
easily be able to take damage from their
shot gun turrets stationed outside the
entrance the door which is ultra
titanium grade will be sealed shut after
Wolverines entrance at which point Kitty
Pryde will phase back through now while
Wolverines adamantium claws would easily
allow him to rip through the titanium
doors the Susan storm is expected to use
her abilities to create a force field
that will contain Wolverine and with his
powers of magnetism magneto will create
an electromagnetic field that will keep
Hydra from allowing Wolverine to escape
by way of teleportation while the reason
for why Hydra the hand and
rain are expected to attack the bunker
isn't initially revealed to us what
we're told by Captain America following
the reveal of his plan is that his
existence is considered a loose and by
Hydra in the hand which seems to be
something that they look to correct and
so while the group is awaiting the
expected arrival of wool rain what we
find is that the proximity alarm goes
off when kitty pryde declares that she's
unable to actually physically see
Wolverine the reason for this is
revealed when Wolverine attached from
the floor with a group realized that he
had actually tunneled underground after
making quick work of Susan storm and
with a plan in complete and total
disarray magneto uses his powers to
seize Wolverines adamantium bones to
hold him in place
however hydrogen teleports Wolverine
Behind Magneto and in the surprise
Magneto's concentration lapses providing
wool frame with a chance to deal the
killing blow with Kitty Pryde and
Captain America as the last two left
Wolverine turns of sights on Steve
Rogers and plunging his claws into the
skull of Captain America and killing him
Wolverine turns to Kitty Pryde after
attempting to reason with wool rain but
recalling all the heroes he had killed
including Iron Man The Punisher
daredevil Black Panther and Ben Grimm
the Kitty Pryde comes to the realization
that Wolverine is beyond redemption as a
result
Kitty Pryde phases her hand into the
skull of Wolverine and after solidifying
loses her hand but kills Wolverine in
the process as his brain is unable to
heal itself completely a following the
death of Wolverine Nick Fury and Elektra
the last remaining heroes on earth
arrived at the bunker while Kitty Pryde
appears to have gone missing Nick Fury
states that she was the plan all along
as the only person capable of being
immune to wolf rain due to her ability
to faze Nick Fury was counting on her
willingness to let go of Wolverine
allowing her the opportunity to deal the
killing blow
so while Wolverine enemy of the state is
considered one of the best Wolverine
stories the what if counterpart fell
remarkably short due to the fact that
the story was released during the same
time as Marvel's civil war the story
itself went largely unnoticed by readers
and reviewers selling less than 33,000
issues with its initial release the
story fell from a ranking of 78 to below
the top 100 within the first few weeks
while no reviews exist for the story as
far as I can locate my own experience
left me with the feeling of this story
coming off as very primitive and basic
without any real merit or premise as if
the basis was to simply capitalize on
the previous concept of Punisher killing
the Marvel Universe and using a
character with a more familiar name with
that being said we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it and I will catch you
guys later peace